and welcome back to the jazz I don't
blame you already I'm coughing in
internally we want to talk about
something else but talk about this today
so anyway welcome everyone back to the
podcast it's good to be back we took a
little time off of the holidays we hope
everyone's holidays were awesome and fun
and great and 2018 has started off
interestingly I guess I could say so
today that's what we talking about is
the whole Logan ball situation but first
we have some cool things okay we have
sponsors and I'm gonna read you the
sponsors really quickly because you know
we're gonna grab every bit of positivity
we can today they keep our show alive
they keep our show alive first off me
and these guys me Andy's the dopest
underwear you could buy three times
softer than cotton they have brand new
designs all the time ships right to your
house okay right now you guys can get
20% off and free shipping with the cool
I'm wearing them right now I wear them
all the time as it might I have too many
pairs with boy shorts with like a palm
tree designer yeah and you know guys if
you're thinking about a gym membership
maybe just start with the me undies okay
then go then go for the gym but trust me
you will love them and he's gonna meet
uneasy calm / annejulien
for 20% off and free shipping Thank You
Mandy's also guys tracker the tiny
device that prevents you from losing all
your important items it's a little
tracker connects to the app on your
phone the tracker pixel is very very
useful I use it all the time right now
if you go to the tracker that's th e TR
ACK our comm slash Jenna Julian you get
20% off your first order when you go
there guys it's a really small
investment for something that can really
give you a lot of peace of mind for all
your important electronics and
everything else you have Thank You
tracker and lastly we have a new sponsor
guys it is quip is the electric
toothbrush that looks like it was
designed by Apple is so clean looking
but it also makes your teeth clean
looking and
affordable and it's affordable guys it's
really dope okay so right now it starts
it's just $25 and right now when you go
to get quick comm slash Jenna Julian you
your first free refill pack you get it
first your first refill pack for free so
you don't even you don't need to pay for
the first refill they'll give it to you
but it's a really cool item it's a
electric toothbrush for those who don't
want to spend a bunch of money on one
and I need a an affordable but reliable
and get quit so get equipped comm slash
annejulien check it out thank you
sponsors thank you sponsors wow look I'm
like I feel I feel like I need more
caffeine for this conversation but I
also feel like there's not enough
caffeine for this commerce in the world
I also just want to say I know you guys
are most of you that listen and watch
the podcast like you know this is a
podcast like you know a lot of it is
like we're just here having a
conversation so maybe we're not going to
say everything perfectly and like even
just trying to gather information and
things for this it feels like this
frustrating mess it's like the most
frustrating jigsaw puzzle to try and sit
down and like organize and lay out so I
think the best way for us to do it is to
just talk about it so forgive us if we
don't say everything perfectly I guess
yeah no it's that's a good point yeah
it's a conversation like a puzzle I
don't want to put together yeah and the
reality is you know after after
something happens where everyone's
talking about it there's only so much
that can really be like said about it so
I kind of feel like when the whole logan
paul thing happened and then all the
videos were happening afterwards i kind
of just like i watched a bunch of them
and then i stopped watching them when
they were popping up because i felt like
a lot of them were just kind of
repeating themselves with that said
though i think a conversation should be
had you know on the issue no matter who
wants to have it it's just i want to be
able to bring some sort of new aspect or
dynamic or thought yeah and i'm I'm
gonna try my very best to stay calm yeah
get too angry not get too upset because
I know that that is a lot of people's
feeling right now and you are entitled
to feel that way because some of the
stuff that's been on YouTube is is
disturbing and upsetting deeply
unsettling to a lot of people and you're
justified in that and you're justified
in your anger why don't we just start
with how this happened so like I I woke
up was it New Year's Day I think I think
was the first yeah it was the first
really quickly we got these new mics
we're still figuring out the levels and
everything so you just got to talk a
little close to it yeah that helps you
patient with me I woke up New Year's Day
I think or you know you've taken a nap
or something so we were watching hi I'm
REE Drummond welcome to my frontier
here's what's happening on the ranch
those were happier times and Julian says
to me he was like did you see Logan
Paul's video and I was like no no I
didn't know you know a normal 30 year
old woman's response to did you see look
at those video and he was like he went
to the Japanese suicide forest okay go
and um you know film to someone that had
commit suicide and I was like all right
I want to watch the video so I did I
fasted a little bit to see the part
where they got to the forest and where
he filmed this person's body and my
first initial reaction was I it was so
incredibly difficult to watch and not
Anna like I mean you watch documentaries
watch crime shows like you've seen
footage of people who have died before
you know I was a juror on a murder trial
I watched a video of a crime scene above
those like a very real experience yeah
it was disturbing to see it but I was
overwhelmed with the sense of this is so
wrong like I I feel so disrespectful
seeing this I even just watching even
watching it I feel like I'm being
disrespectful to that person and their
family and I continue to watch it
through to the end and Julian looked at
me and was like why are you still
watching that like
you watching it and I was like I want to
see I want to see how about it is I want
to see the whole thing and I want to see
how that it is and obviously we I was
desperately trying to milk this two week
vacation we've given ourselves and you
know people just come in with we need to
hear what you think we want to hear what
you think and this is sort of the nature
of our platform is that I'm I'm angry at
YouTube and we'll get into that but
we're self-policing
and it's important to talk about this
stuff and people are very angry and very
upset and they should be and they should
be talking about it there's a lot of
sketchy stuff going on and I want to
talk a little bit about Logan and what I
think about his current situation and
there's just so much to talk about here
that I'm like I don't yeah I don't even
know where to start
all right you know I think I agree I
think it's it's a little overwhelming
just think about the whole situation but
I want to first just touch on a couple
things I think we should go from like
the initial reaction we had to kind of
seeing where it went in terms of like
how YouTube dealt with it and like the
way it played out because of what
YouTube did or didn't do for that matter
and then moving forward like what we
think of the situation as it stands
today yeah to be perfectly honest I I
try not to like consume too many like
vlogs and that's different than it used
to be for me because when I started
vlogging and I was early in vlogging I
felt like that was like doing homework
and that's something Jenna you know gave
me a lot of insight to when I start
making YouTube videos like you got to
know what's out there it's it's doing
your homework to know the landscape of
what type of video you're making so
initially I watched a lot of hogs and it
helped me a lot even just to know what I
didn't want to make but it just gives
you an idea of what the landscape of
that type of video looks like which is
so important if you're going to be a
creator you need to be educated on your
field that doesn't that's not the same
anymore I don't watch pretty much any
vlog ever and a big reason for that is
because I feel like the the idea of
vlogging has become so
centered around shocking people for the
sake of a video a thumbnail and a couple
views but then forgetting what that
means for real life and those two are so
separated nowadays in vlogs you see the
shock factor you see running around man
on the street type of stuff you see like
a lot of really annoying stuff you know
there's there's a lot of good blogs out
there but there's also a lot of [ __ ]
that I just really I don't really want
to consume and I think it's because it
makes me feel like I'm watching
something that didn't really need to be
created for that stupid vlog because the
cause of what what it required to happen
in life and I think this this video that
Logan made is it is a prime example of
that my initial reaction of the video
was like wow I can't believe that I
clicked on this video that's titled we
found a dead body and Japanese suicide
forest and then I actually saw that
pretty much all of it you know the
blurred face really didn't do anything
and what got to me the most like Jenna
had said you know you've watched you've
watched Dateline
you were on a murder trial you you've
been disturbed to a sense of from seeing
different aspects of death for me this
was different than anything I've ever
seen because of the fact that it was in
a real vlog and that's what I'm so
familiar with that medium is is like
home to me I've vlogged for a lot of
years now and I've even vlogged in Japan
which Jen and I I feel like we should
definitely you know I feel like we
should talk about that but like is that
Kermit crying out there yeah why don't
you just let him in he's in a cry he
needs a hug I don't blame him but yeah I
also want to talk about that because
it's something that I thought about a
lot because obviously there's videos
that came out after the original suicide
forest video that we the unicorns have
put together a compilation of his other
Japan vlogs that were all equally
offensive and a youtuber broad named
Verena Scully had made a really good
video talking about how his whole
attitude towards their culture towards
their country it's like it reminded her
I'm not speaking for her it's like yeah
I want you to watch her video so you can
hear it in her words but like it
reminded her
of the way that she and her family were
treated by other people because she was
foreign and they think she's so cute and
they talked down to her
it's like Logan sort of treated a lot of
Japan like a cartoon culture and had
almost no respect for them as people
which is why he was able to film someone
who had taken their own life and
seemingly felt almost nothing and I
don't want it I don't really feel like
getting into the conversation of his
body language in the laughing and
whatever it was it was disrespectful and
and other youtubers have pointed out
that yeah your content is like we're
going to the suicide forest but like
there's definitely a kernel in there
where he's like I hope we find a dead
body or I hope all we're sleeping over
in this forest someone comes in here to
kill themselves and we the Loghain dab
dab dab can sit down and talk them out
of it you know what a great video is I
want to talk about some of that in a
little bit but like the the Japan thing
it's like it is you and I are both
Americans that have gone to Japan yeah
as I'm sure a lot of you are or I don't
know whatever it is it's so difficult to
go to Japan and Tokyo
in particular and not be overwhelmed by
the sense of respect that is just
everywhere everything everywhere you go
it's I would before I saw that video I
would almost say it's impossible to go
there as an American with our American
values and our American culture and not
be affected by it in a positive way like
it's really hard to go there and just be
like [ __ ] this [ __ ] everything whatever
it's so powerful to sit with the way
that they think they do things
differently in terms of respect than us
it's so admirable that those parts of
their their society their culture are so
moving for us as Americans where it's
all like me driven independent driven
like me before everybody else I'll do
whatever I want [ __ ] everybody this like
you can get a white picket fence you can
reach with the Stars the the limits are
endless for you as a person and to go
there and it's so difficult and
be moved by that how they treat their
belongings how they treat other people
how they treat children how they treat
people on a train yeah it's like their
food the item the issue the issue for me
when the unicorn's video came out
showing the rest of the vlogs in Japan
which by the way all it took for them to
make that video was literally watching
his other vlogs which which makes you
wonder and it begs the question which
I'm not gonna waste my [ __ ] time but
it begs the question how many vlogs did
this guy make going around doing god
knows what God knows where and
disrespected the [ __ ] out of something
that you might really feel like annoyed
by and annoyed to the point where like
wow that's embarrassing that that guy
does what I do or that guy's
embarrassing cuz he's from my country or
that guy's embarrassing cuz he's he's
just downright you know disrespectful
person whatever my problem is if if I'm
sitting here and I have never traveled
to Japan all I've seen from Japan are
things on TV YouTube the internet
whatever I've heard of how it is there
I've watched movies I've met people who
lived there this and that but I've never
been to Japan and I watched that video
I'm like wow that's that's pretty [ __ ]
up like I feel like that's really
disrespectful and that makes me angry
but like Jenna said like you just said
the fact that we were there and we got
to feel every single day that we were
there we got to feel like that respect
and that culture shock in the most
positive life-changing way every day we
were there wherever we went
whoever we talked to walking around at 3
a.m. watching like we walk down a street
at 3 a.m. in Japan and not only was it
like silent to the point where you can
hear a mouse run down the street but
there were bikes leaned up against
houses not locked up no one no one's
there's no stealing all you know all
over the place there
there's umbrellas that people take from
certain establishments use them and drop
them at other other establishments and
no one steals them that's why that
system works the cabs are pristine clean
we met a cab driver who spent his entire
day the day before he picked us up
trying to find a guy who left his wallet
in his cab like everyone who we had met
and every place we had gone to we just
felt like
a conflicting feeling of like damn
America can be really like really
disrespectful and like I didn't even
think of this like I don't even think of
a society that existed like this and
today in today's you know time and age
and then we go home and we're like wow
like and I mean culture shock because we
don't we had never I mean personally I
had never given the thought that a place
like that with people who respected each
other who were complete strangers and
respected just the well-being of the
community and cleanliness and peace
existed today like that seems like a
utopian kind of fake idea until you go
to Japan and then you see it and so for
that to be our experience in Japan and
something that like we'll never forget
we've talked about that long before this
video came out we'll never forget our
trips to Japan for that to be our
experience and then see the Logan video
it's just there's no words it's it's
like it's the like we we misstep a
little bit in Japan on accident like we
say the wrong thing or we accidentally
you know we feel horrible so for that
video to come out it's like holy [ __ ] I
mean yes and I agree with you on all of
those things and I want to clarify that
like as youtubers ourselves you know
we're not in a position to demonize
someone else for making something or you
know we've made mistakes everybody makes
mistakes and I've seen people defending
Logan as this video was a mistake he
apologized for it and I've also seen HOF
you guys comparing my fish apology video
to his apology I laugh it makes me laugh
okay you guys are funny but like I just
think it's the difference between how
how someone handles a bad decision you
know like the length of time I don't
think has anything to do with it I for
my apology video I was I was sitting
with the fact I think a lot of people
missed the point of that and continue to
miss the point of that but I was sitting
with the fact that I'm a vegan and I
care about animals and I put animals in
a place where they shouldn't have been
and I was sitting with that guilt and
the guilt was overwhelming and if
someone you know genuinely feels bad for
something that they've done I think you
can tell you know it doesn't need to be
a big long thing or a drawn-out thing
and I think a lot of people are
set because they can't they aren't
convinced or they can't fully tell if
Logan feels bad for what he did or if
what he did he thinks is even wrong
because if you're gonna play the other
side of this there are lots of other
YouTube videos in the Japanese suicide
forest going around Tokyo or other
countries or other places being really
disrespectful and annoying I mean just
look at jackass this is their whole
thing for years and years and years how
loud and obnoxious can we be you know so
it's not that I'm so everywhere I mean
he's gained however over a million
subscribers since then probably I think
he's not losing subscribers so it's
important to talk about and I think even
like when I was a younger person you
know I listen to questionable music I
listen to or watch questionable things
my mom would let me do stuff like that
and I understand there are a lot of kids
and a lot of people they look up to
Logan and like Logan a lot and what he
did was not okay and what YouTube is
doing is not okay and I feel like what
was important about what my mom taught
me was you get to decide whether or not
you like them you know having a
conversation with kids well and it's not
if you're a parent because I'm not a
parent
I don't have a kid I'm not telling you
how to parent but like your younger
sisters your cousins your brothers you
know your neighbors talking to them
about it and helping them understand
that you can really enjoy someone a lot
maybe they just like the fact that he's
entertaining and up just a young guy you
know you don't have to get it but what
you do have to get is that that person
is not infallible and they do make
mistakes and then it's okay to call them
out on it you know I mean I think that
that's the role of the YouTube community
here is that because YouTube is not
doing apps like anything at all it's up
to us it's up to people who own the con
the platform and and this clearly has
not hurt him in any way shape or form
it's important to talk about it it's
important to talk about with with your
like little family members your little
friends that are Logan Paul fans you
know I don't think it's a it's an
effective strategy like for example I
liked corn in like Marilyn Manson and
like prodigy growing up
stuff that would just make your parent
be like oh my god are you okay like are
you gonna be okay when you grow up and
worried about you because some of it's
really not okay for a fourteen-year-old
I get it but my mom would always let us
listen to whatever music we liked she
would talk to us about what was in in
the song rose in the show or like you
know that that this part of that is not
okay and that you know they're
expressing some of it like it's art in
music or maybe in film or in television
but it's so important to have a
conversation with your kid and I think
maybe a lot of people a lot of parents a
lot of friends be like you can't watch
that you turn it off it's [ __ ] trash
Logan Paul is trash [ __ ] cut it out
but maybe an important strategy here is
because clearly people are going to
continue watching him is to just have a
conversation with the younger people in
your life that you can you can really
enjoy someone as an actor or a musician
whatever but if they do something that
crosses the line you have to let them
know and and you you do decide as a
person what your values are does that
does that align with your values and
it's not just your kid on their iPad or
on their phone checking out youtubers
like Iggy the that's what scares me the
most is the way parents kind of
generalize like okay they're on the
internet they're just watching their
YouTube their buddy anymore
but they're not paying attention to what
that is and in fact they're not only not
paying attention but like in the case of
when like kids are going to Jake Paul's
house and the parents were there with
them
that's that's how [ __ ] far remove
these people are from reality and
scruples and morals is the fact that
they they're like yeah yeah you know the
mmm I imagine their conversation with
friends like yeah yeah no I'm gonna take
my my [ __ ] son to do this thing with
the youtuber and then I'll meet you
later
not knowing what the [ __ ] is going on
yeah nothing any [ __ ] clue that
that's that's a reality for that person
you know regardless of how that
situation played out but really quick
there was so many tweets going around
like the ones you know referring to
suicide hotlines and if you need help
talk you know so many tweets that were
being highly retweeted when this whole
video initially dropped and one tweet
that stuck out to me was
Hey really quickly parents who are on
Twitter there is a video going around
right now that your kid probably is
going to see or has seen yeah maybe
consider having a talk with them which
is such like a you know an oversight to
most people but it's like that's the
reality of this it's like this is not
just another YouTube video in the sub
box like you parents need to wake up and
I think the parent thing is such a good
like a good point but it's like this
this is so and that's what that's the
gravity of the situation that's what
sucks so much but it's also like a good
it's a good note to for parents to be
like okay well this is not just I don't
know it's like YouTube is no YouTube is
not family-friendly like you can't just
assume that everything on there is gonna
be peaches when in fact this could do
real damage and probably already has
done a lot of real damage to kids well I
mean I think the important thing is we
see this all the time at me & Greets we
hear this all the time just on the
street just wherever when we meet
parents and they go yeah I have no clue
who you are but my kid loves you so you
know it's great you see interviews with
parents waiting in line for Jake Paul's
house for example which is a petting zoo
back whenever and they're like yeah I
don't know what the kid is but like my
daughter's love them so like I'll do
anything for them it's not cute it's not
funny
it's not okay you're not being a good
parent yeah for you to not know what
your kids are into I'm not saying again
I'm bringing it back to the point that I
made about the way that my mom parented
me which is I'm not saying you should
dictate what they can and can't listen
to you and I know just as well that if
there's something you're not allowed to
see you're gonna eventually find a way
to see it because you're a little [ __ ]
kit and you find out how to watch things
you're not allowed to watch you know
what I mean rated our movies and
whatever it'll sneak into a movie
theater kids are gonna figure out how to
watch it by telling them don't watch
that person he's trash I'm not sure as
an effective strategy but a conversation
is an effective strategy and it's it
pisses me off that I've seen couple
videos with parents being like I'm
having a conversation with my my son
about this and where my daughter my
younger sister or cousin you know
because them just being blind to it
maybe doesn't help them either there's a
there's a level of decision-making that
I think is really important for young
people to have when they decide what
they want to watch and not watch and it
shouldn't always be at their parents
discretion like I do think it's
important for a 13 year old to be like I
liked Logan Paul but I don't think I
like him anymore you know and to have a
talk with a caring adults that says well
why do you feel that way well because
the alternative is they go into their
fandom Twitter DM group and they
encourage each other about how Logan
made a mistake and everyone's an idiot
for criticizing him and then all of a
sudden they're back in that warped kind
of world where they don't have any input
from reality or any parental advice on
any of this or even just like someone to
talk to who's not like a low gang right
like I don't know that's it we're in the
age of social media right where our
parents were like you know if you listen
to Madonna there's so much sexual stuff
in there you can't listen to that I mean
like that only gets you so far but
you're in a time in space where everyone
theoretically has a voice and can use it
I think it's important to teach your
kids like this person is literally no
different than you they are on a
democratized platform if they're doing
something that you don't think is right
it doesn't matter if you're 11 your you
should feel that way you know what I
mean you you're entitled to feel that
way you're important and you matter in
this space you know whereas in years ago
it was like they can just get away with
ignorant racist annoying [ __ ] for years
until someone made a big enough stink
about it to get it off the air yeah you
know yeah doesn't work that way everyone
has opinion everyone has an equal
opinion now and honestly it's like one
of the most intimidating parts of this
whole issue is is watching like the the
fallout from his fans and like seeing
how I despite the fact that he like even
in his apology video was like don't
defend me you like you see the I mean
I've looked around and I've seen some
really weird [ __ ] up like it scares me
how mindless people are in how they and
how they follow who they follow and how
little they think about things just
objective
every once in a while and I think such
an important part of growing up is like
teaching yourself a moral compass so to
speak and like you develop a moral
compass from your surroundings the
people you meet your teachers your peers
but teaching yourself your own version
of it is such an important thing in
growing up into an adult or in a young
adult and the huge problem with
youtubers and youtubers like logan paul
who have these massive followings and
again you're not responsible for what
every fan of yours does but the problem
is like it just really discourages the
idea of like let's objectively think
about what's right and what's wrong for
a second there's so much groupthink
happening that it's almost like a lost
cause to try to way what what is a good
thing and what's a bad thing because if
the person who you liked it it that
discussion isn't happening with anyone
well I mean one of the things I also
wanted to talk about this before we get
into all the YouTube responsibilities
yeah we can do a little break before the
yeah is is sort of along the lines of
what you just said and I feel like I
have a couple of things that I would say
to Logan directly first first of which
is I want to be careful you know we're
talking openly and honestly about this
topic as a lot of people are in the
internet but I want to be careful about
the mob mentality in the demonizing
someone you know what I think he did was
it's really irresponsible really
insensitive and really terrible and he
should be criticized for it but I do I
don't want to contribute to the the mob
mentality well it's just not productive
at this no it's not but but talking
about it is productive and we know that
that makes real change on the internet
yeah having a conversation I agree
another thing that I want to talk about
is that we do know from experience and
from the experience of other youtubers
or content creators is that your job is
very unique especially if your job is to
share your life every single day the
monotony of that is just mind-blowing
where you're I know a lot of you aspire
to be vloggers and you do it and you
want to do it and everybody sort of hits
this same wall of like I'm only one
person
and life is relatively boring when
you're living it and you know a lot of
it is filled with you entertaining
yourself by watching something else or
playing a game we're talking with your
friends or petting your dog or going for
a walk
silent I'm asleep right now and it gets
very difficult to entertain people with
you only being yourself so I get the
path for a lot of vloggers turns into
this alright well let's start
structuring in some vacations some trips
let's travel let's go places let's do
things
let's structure in activities during the
day so that we can have some inferi
content and if there wasn't already
people that have been doing this for
years if this was like the first time
that a vlogger has done something over
the top and people are upset about it
I'd be like okay
but unfortunately for Logan and Jake
even Jake it's plenty to talk about with
Jake but like there's been a decade of
people that have come before you that
have made open and honest vlogs about
their struggles and how it has ruined
their lives their relationships their
financial situations a lot of their
friendships their businesses it's
destroyed a lot for them because they've
put their their entertainment first and
I think that this vlog in the Japanese
suicide forest was a perfect example of
someone who has been putting
entertainment first so much that they
have forgotten how to be a person right
like if you're running any other
business people comes first you need to
have good people if you're working with
a bad person or bad people it doesn't
matter how great it is with what it is
that you're making or whatever you have
bad people around you people first in
the sense that like you're putting
yourself first your morals first he's
completely lost track of everything
that's not content you know because if
people came first you would get yourself
in that situation and be like oh my god
this is not content this is not okay you
know but he's in the the actual thick of
that where it's like everything is
content and I have now lost myself as a
person and I know we we hear about these
stories of people who have sold their
soul to the devil for fame and success
and blah blah blah if that's just if you
took that as a loose interpretation
something like this is an example of
that you have forgotten who you are as a
person or what even makes a human being
a human being
that a person that has committed suicide
that is hanging from a tree is still a
person and not content that is sort of
in my definition you have now sold your
soul you are no longer a person you are
doing everything for your job
your entertainment your money whether or
not you monetize the video or not
because I don't I don't care about those
details about how he hadn't monetized it
and it just didn't get taken down and
you usually put on training its content
you have put in you put your job your
entertainment everything in front of
just being a good person that that's me
is the definition of selling your soul
your there's nothing in there anymore
and I will tell you that you know his
channel is growing so I don't I'm trying
my best not to do this like bandwagon
slam fest and I did someone was like you
defended Logan Paul and in the other
podcast and I'm not sure that I did I'm
I I talked about how my personal
interactions with him had gone and that
he was professional he was on time he
had reached out to me years ago when he
wanted to drop out of school to pursue
YouTube and ask my thoughts on it I'm an
education pusher I of course was like I
think you should stay in school but he
should ultimately do what's right with
you I'm not sure that's offending
someone but I take your criticism but
like for all of this I just I don't know
well he's lost himself as a person well
in his job and you I will tell you how
difficult it is you have lost the
respect of the community and yes your
channel is growing and yes you're doing
well and people will continue to watch
you but when I don't I think people
vastly underestimate just how difficult
it is to remain in any industry when you
have lost the respect of your peers and
colleagues it's really hard and we do
have some control and that
people don't [ __ ] with you anymore
people aren't gonna work with you
anymore people aren't gonna hang out to
you anymore and I know you're a maverick
and a lone wolf and you think you can do
everything by yourself because you're a
22 year old kid who's on a rocket ship
and thinks nothing can stop them that's
not true it is so incredibly difficult
to exist in a space where nobody has
your back and that is incredibly
isolating and lonely I think we've seen
that a number of times within the
YouTube community
you don't mean mmm-hmm I think I think
that's a really good point the the idea
of someone like being detached with
reality because of how far gone they are
down this hole of like being making
content all the time and then being the
most trending and being edgy and making
shocking things and having a brand
that's bigger than anything in the world
right and I think the choices he made
that in order to have documented what he
documented and posted what he's posted
and reacted how he reacted those choices
were all like you said blinded
completely by numbers and ego and and
his own brand and trending and this and
that but I don't think it's that like I
think that's such a good point and you
can relate it to the before and after as
well like if you look at the the videos
of him running around disrespecting the
[ __ ] out of everything and everyone in
him in that foreign country that is all
about respect all of all of what he was
thinking wasn't like I want to go be an
[ __ ] it's on one content I want to
make shocking [ __ ] I want my buddies to
film it I want to be funny I want to see
a ton of [ __ ] comments telling me how
funny and entertaining this was I want
it to trend I want a million views I
want a billion views whatever that's all
that was on his mind it's not like Logan
is like this horrible evil man who's
going around doing these things he's
lost he's just completely clouded by
this idea that he needs to be number one
at whatever the [ __ ] he's trying to be
number one at which in the Internet age
it's so goddamn convoluted now it's like
I mean what if what is even the goal
right like what could what more could
you want right but I want to relate what
you said in addition to before the after
and the after
meaning the apology video that he made
because it really was one of the most
infuriating parts of this whole thing
for me because it was so rehearsed and
so bad and so disingenuous to me this is
my opinion like you could have had any
different reaction to that apology video
but for me it's like he wakes up whoever
his people are whatever might have told
him hey that tweet you sent out wasn't
received well we need to make a real
video let's time let's address it I need
you to be like let's be real genuine
let's let's apologize this is not and
Logan being the actor that he is because
he is an actor this is not my words
those are you know he that's what he
wants to do he's acted in movies before
that's his like thing it felt like I was
watching a stupid audition for some sort
of drama scene in some movie with that
apology video there was no there's no
like pauses there was no um there was no
us there was no uh you know like it was
all just like calculated scripts with
him like looking at it was just oh I
mean I can't even tell you how
uncomfortable I was watching that call
apology video and then after it was over
I felt like no one was sorry I just felt
like it was just another piece of this
whole puzzle that he added on to his
channel and that's another like it would
have been different if he had done the
[ __ ] he had done waited a couple days
gone on camera made a really messy kind
of all over the place but like in some
way genuine apology where he wasn't he
wasn't well-spoken he wasn't well lit he
wasn't yeah I don't know I don't know
anything about the video being genuine
he could have really just conveyed at
least 10% of me that he was that he was
sorry and it would have made me feel
like okay he might be waking up as a
person this whole thing might have woken
him up but the sad thing for me is it
felt like a three-part series where all
three parts he's still not person he's
still lost in that world yeah I mean
absolutely there's nothing worse than a
bad apology like you're not sorry you
know why did you waste our time you got
that reaction yeah you're not sorry and
I between Jake and Logan when all the
things that you know [ __ ] hits a fan
with the two of them and they feel the
need to half-ass apologize or whatever
like you don't have our respect it's
it's as simple as that
and if you want it like you you need to
just stop with the one-up itís like the
the next thing we're gonna do is bigger
and better than ever and I can relate to
some of like almost nothing of what
they're doing but like some of the
internal additive attitude because I do
feel like part of my younger self and my
career was playing a little bit of a
character and a you know an extension of
myself it's not a lie but some of it is
like a little more turned up than I
would usually be which is it like we
having this incredible outlet with the
podcast with live streams and stuff even
vlogs where I like you don't constantly
feel this pressure to be this certain
person 24/7 and I see a lot of that in
both Jake and Logan especially Logan
right now when you look back at some of
his vlogs and what he's doing there he
you can tell that he is trapped in this
box of I need to be over-the-top and
entertaining and if I am NOT that then
I'm not gonna have an audience and
people aren't gonna care maybe maybe
that would happen but I will tell you
from experience as I'm sure a lot of
other people would you have everyone's
attention you've already done the most
difficult thing in the world which is
like not on world but yet just people
vastly underestimate how difficult it is
just to get people to care about what
you're posting or what you have to say
or what you're doing you've already done
all of that you can it is okay to let go
of this like act of oh my god this is so
crazy let's go do something [ __ ]
crazy and nuts and entertaining you know
it's fine it's just being your normal
self
people are already interested in you and
this this is like something in
psychology I think will always stick
with me forever it's like when you're
working with another person the the rule
number one is do no harm
do no harm by the other person like you
can you can it's up to you and your
liberties if you want to disclose things
how you want to work with him how you
want to talk to them what you think
works but rule number one is do no harm
you know and I think that these vlogs
with the we're just silly and crazy and
out of our mind we're Mavericks may be
fine but if rule of
one is do no harm then like 10 minutes
of your 10 on 1 vlog doesn't exist you
know yeah if you're just thinking about
maybe you weren't in this position you
didn't you didn't get into this because
you wanted young kids to look up to you
or you didn't think that this would be
your audience and now you're put in this
position fine whatever I don't care
but you're at this point you know at 15
million people that watch your YouTube
channel do no harm and really think
about it and really sit with it and when
people critique your apology when people
critique what you've done in your vlogs
listen to them
don't just dab on them and say that
they're [ __ ] haters actually listen
to them internalize them think about
them do things differently in the future
like I'm not looking for Jake or Logan
or either of them to just grovel for 10
years and say how sorry they are no one
want that we want to see you grow up and
learn and change you know and have more
of a connection with reality and what
you're putting home
because clearly YouTube's not going to
shut down either of their channels
they're not gonna stop any of it and
kids aren't gonna stop watching them
their channels are only continuing to
grow so what we want and I think what
might do well to start back on the on
the trail of earning your colleagues
respect here is to show some growth and
stop maybe every once in a while take a
break from being a [ __ ] jackass on a
street in foreign country and just be
yourself
I think people you ain't your brother
will find it incredibly liberating to
just be yourself for a little while
and not some over-the-top character and
mind you while all this was going down
there was a leaked video of Jake Paul
saying the n-word and that whole the
video of him saying I lost my virginity
with a thumbnail of Erica Castel sitting
on him just like almost as [ __ ] naked
and those things are like almost non
news because at this point no one even
cares that you just [ __ ] said the
n-word do you understand how little
respect people have for you that when
you you get caught saying the n-word
openly out loud unto you and people are
you almost have nothing to say about it
it's not even it's not even a news piece
nothing to say about it
to the point where we don't respect you
enough to even [ __ ] tear or be angry
or be upset or have anything to say it's
it's it's it's a note it's a no-brainer
to me yeah but it is important you're a
very very very different person than
they are or ever will be and you now
and you ten years ago are different than
they are or ever will be like you're
just a completely different human and I
I want to speak to that really quickly
just that like I've never played a
character so to speak on YouTube like
you know I've made vlogs and I think my
vlogs have before evolved and I've been
a little bit different and things of
whatever but the idea that it's it's
liberating to just kind of be yourself
for a living and not feel like you need
to embellish and be over-the-top I think
that can only resonate so much with a
person who is so and I don't want to say
business minded but I mean like
competitive in the in the world of like
I want to be I would just say ego driven
like egocentric I want to be number one
online I want to be the the this and
that which which you watch them anytime
you hear them talk like when Jake Paul
went on the h3 podcast the things he was
talking about like his goals he's like I
want to be a the the billionaire and I
want to own the it's like all they want
is this like one thing that they want
that's really important for them is just
being so big in the world of like money
and power and what they've created and
where they've come from and this and
that when in reality it's like okay but
before all of that before all of your
accomplishments and everything you've
done online and all your views and
numbers and money like before all of
that don't forget that you need to be a
goddamn human being to other human
beings which is so easy to get lost in
that train of thought and I again I
can't identify with that train of
thought neither can you so you can to me
that says everything about a person yeah
when they when people would ask me what
do you want to be in five years like I
don't know I didn't know what I was
doing five years ago I'm for one don't
even want long-term goals and even if I
did there's vague things like I would
like to be happy or I'd like to not say
goodbye to my dogs was my only tangible
goal when I was about 21 years old I
want to live a life someday where I
don't have to say goodbye to my dogs
like
4:7 that's what I want for my future and
I'm living that and I'm living the dream
but I don't I I just cannot relate to
someone whose goals are like I want a
billion dollars okay well then guess
what that kind of person who has no
other kind of goals other than being the
biggest the best the most rich it that
says everything I need to know about 100
persons you are willing to do all the
gross disgusting things that not all the
time but oftentimes goes into being that
person which makes that human a person
who's prone to just being a bad person
other people right and I want to say
like everything you're saying I
personally agree with I think is sound
and I think it's good advice for anyone
to listen to whose loss and needs advice
but at the same time you need to
remember that you're not that person and
as much as you don't identify with that
they might not identify with you
a person whose goal is to just make
money and be powerful like all those
people who have those goals are not all
about people but they are there are a
lot of times very prone to being less of
a humanitarian and a friendly neighbor
to the the average person having any
kind of balance or a moral compass
because you have such you such blinders
on and I and I I think you made a great
point but it's it's just important
remember that a lot of people who have
those goals are wired like that they may
see no value in what you just said and
there's not really a tangible problem
with that which is and well here's my
thing so I feel like I know a lot of
adults like this and I've known a lot of
people like this in my whole life
Jake Paul and Logan Paul are both young
men they're very driven they're very
excited for their careers yeah they've
made a lot of mistakes and I guess we're
going down the road of which is worse
and worse and worse and we're watching
from the outside and it's we see the
harm that it is causing but it's it's
somehow admirable for a 22 year old to
be so hungry to achieve their dreams and
success like young kids see him as a
success story they're inspired by him
they're inspire so hard work inspired by
his mansion to me as an adult and when I
see other adults like this there's
nothing admirable to me about your work
ethic to
you have no friends no relationship
nothing in your life other than your job
it's easy to throw yourself into a job
and forget that other human beings exist
that to me is selfish fine do whatever
you want to do but I know a lot of
people who become lawyers doctors and
they just forget about everybody else
good for you
you've done so great in your career but
what's what I think is impressive and
someone is who can balance things you
know people who have kids and a
boyfriend or girlfriend or friends that
they like to take care of parents that
they like to check in on you know like
there's nothing admirable to me about
burying your head into your work and
just denying that the rest of the world
exists and that's why I feel like this
is sort of going down this like career
before everything and you do see the
people in the wake and the fallout
making these exposed videos about Jake
and Logan being like yeah dude I was
part of team 10 and like dude he
actually was like kind of a dick to me
and like not nice and you know a lot of
it sounds like it's coming between like
money and business sort of ruining his
interpersonal relationships not
surprised at all because it sounds like
someone who was so focused yeah and
guess what if all you want in life is
money you'll get it and you won't get
anything [ __ ] else you won't be happy
you'll be [ __ ] miserable it doesn't
matter if you're not happy before you
have money you're not gonna be happy
after you get money you will never be
happy and the people around you will
never be happy you'll be miserable on
the inside so go I I think kids are
allowed to decide whatever they want and
like and I hope that they see some of
the the I don't know the difference
between something that is truly
admirable and something that's not I
agree I agree and I think the narrative
of youtubers telling their audience in
the world how [ __ ] hard their work is
just so exhausted god I'm so [ __ ]
yeah it's a snoozefest and every you
know everyone who does that and will
relentlessly tweet about their grind and
their schedule and all the work I mean
just
first of all just shut the [ __ ] up and
second of all second of all the work
that's really being done that really
[ __ ] matters to the world is the work
that you're not
[ __ ] tweeting about 24/7 okay so even
if you're not like Jenna and you don't
and and you you may have like uh you
know I I believe in hard work and that's
all that matters and jobs is all that
matters maybe you believe maybe that's
what you think
and maybe that's how you live your life
and that's totally [ __ ] fine but I
think even you that person will agree
with me when I say maybe just [ __ ] do
it and stop talking about it it's not
preaching to people of how lazy they are
and how bad they're worth it work out
how you set yourself apart from the
world by your grind shut up just do it
just there's no like what you're doing
is such a step backwards ten step
backwards for any hard work that you
might have actually done which I don't
even know if you have because all I see
is you tweeting about it and posing
these videos we were like what part of a
sports team like have you ever actually
been on a team of people or is it always
just you because the person on your
sports team that acted like that didn't
get very far if they're just like hustle
and grind and everyone else around me is
lazy know who's your most admirable
teammate the one you could depend on
that would just do [ __ ] and not [ __ ]
save [ __ ] that is the person that you
want to be I don't know I feel like when
I was a kid a lot of people that I liked
celebrities that I liked celebrities had
a crush on but all of my role models
were like tangible people that like did
something that I found admirable you
know it means yeah or even now as an
adult it's not like I you know someone
who's untouchable in terms of talent or
wealth or you know it's it's somebody
like [ __ ] Joe Rogan man like I'll
Alec seth macfarlane Oh like I like my
mom I'd like to be my mom when I grow up
you know someone who you're like this is
why I like them and it has nothing to do
with them being good-looking or wealthy
or grind or grinding every day I think I
think now is a good point where I just
okay I want to talk about some news real
quick because when you're frustrated and
you're annoyed and you're seeing [ __ ]
all over the internet and you're sweaty
you just need some soft goddamn undies
and me and these has you covered guys
it's made from a sustainably sourced
natural soft fabric that's three times
off from the cotton and I say this every
time if you've never felt the me undies
in person three times often cotton
sounds good but you're like I don't know
what does that really mean once you
touch the me undies once you put
you understand right away how much of a
difference that is me and ease are so
[ __ ] comfortable I literally wear
them every single day and they don't
wear down they are incredibly made they
have really cool designs on it just to
top it all off three times awesome
cotton I mean ridiculously soft okay
guys you're allowed to switch between
membership plans cancel or skip a month
at any time right now me and ease has an
exclusive offer just for the dink femme
guys until January 20th you get 20% off
your membership and free shipping this
20% 20% off an already discounted
membership ok Amy and he's a social that
you'll love their underwear even a
hundred percent satisfaction guarantee
is is yours okay if you don't like them
for whatever reason and you're crazy you
can send it back and but we're fund you
for your full purchase right now go to
meet undies comm slash Jenna Julian
that's Emmy undies dot-com slash
annejulien
to get that deal you will not be sorry
I'm telling you just try it also guys
tracker a wonderful sponsor the podcast
guys stop losing your stuff I know
you're losing your stuff put the tiny
tracker pixel on your keychain on your
on the back your phone on your book bag
on your laptop case like things that you
really can't be losing just put them in
there that's all it is then you have the
peace of mind wherever you go that if
you lose that item you have a tracker
pixel in there with you okay
it's the Bluetooth tracking device that
links to their app on your phone where
you can GPS locate every tracker that
you have on your stuff and you can label
them so for instance I have my drone
tracked I have my camera bag tracked so
if I ever want to see where I am when
I'm traveling and I see where my bags
are they're slow on the turnstile where
are they oh they're at LAX okay I'm good
it's just peace of mind that's all it is
okay and it's tiny it's a really like
inconspicuous great thing that you can
even play a noise so if you're losing it
in the house you can play a noise on it
it'll it'll ring in the other room you
find it right away really awesome guys
right now you can get tracker you can
get 20% off your order when you go to
the tracker that's th e TR ACK our coms
last time and Julian that's 20% off your
order an already really really fair
price item that you're just not gonna be
sorry for it's an investment you're
gonna make and then realize you need to
make
and lastly guys if you're looking for an
awesome new toothbrush but you don't
want to spend a ton of money quip
has you covered okay
it's an electric toothbrush that looks
like it was designed by Apple it's
really sleek its minimalist its
beautiful and it packs the right amount
of vibrations into an ultra slim design
with guided pulses to simplify better
brushing at a fraction of the cost and
I'm telling you like you look you go
down that section at the drugstore with
a particular it's insanely expensive
nowadays they're behind plastic you
can't even get them yourself you can't
yeah you have to call the attendant to
come over and lock it because it's such
anyway okay there's no cluttering up
your bathroom the equip comes with a
little mount that goes right on your
mirror and it also doubles as a travel
cover so you can mount it it's not on
your counter it's beautifully like it's
just simple it's easy okay
and right now quip offers an optional
subscription plan delivering new
toothbrush heads on a dentist
recommended three months scheduled for
just five dollars including free
shipping worldwide and you eat your
first refill free when you go to get
quip that's GE t qu IP comm slash
annejulien and you get your first refill
pack for free check it out you will not
be sorry
thank you sponsors thank you sponsors
okay so i think it would be easy to kind
of go all day but i think we should
finish with youtube and I know how angry
you are about this and I know that like
this is this is hard this is hard to
talk about in in words the like you know
people are just gonna take weird and
twist and you know be upset about no
matter what you say so this is really
hard
we're trying really hard I'm trying hard
I know you are you know I know
and really quick just so everyone who's
under Iraq knows Logan's video with the
dead body and it was on the training
page for a long time and it was there
until Logan himself took the video down
YouTube do not remove it then his
apology video lived on the training page
for about two and a half days right
caned about 20 million views whether it
was monetized or not I don't I don't
even think we need to go in that like
who the [ __ ] knows personally I don't
really [ __ ] think it matters at all
you know monetizing a video by the way
isn't the only
way to benefit from that video being
online and being shared he has gained
like he gained like 80,000 subscribers
in one day last week mm-hmm and he's the
views and the the my point is monetizing
a video just because someone doesn't
monetize a video or there's no ads on a
video doesn't make them a saint for for
that okay like the video is still being
shared still being uploaded there were
still a choice to it anyway back to the
YouTube issue which I think kind of
revolves around the fact that what
YouTube has been policing in the past
year and a half whatever with all the D
monetization and all the control over
what they think is Dima bowl or is
deemed suitable for advertisers and what
isn't has been such a hot topic recently
so the fact that they allowed this video
to stay up it's just a bit mind-bending
I don't I personally still don't
understand how that happened I don't
understand how they haven't really even
said anything about it I also just think
the cherry on top is the fact that his
apology video trended for so long number
one like I just the YouTube red golden
boy like I don't know man I I don't know
I don't I I think it is it I don't know
what it's difficult to figure out words
right now because I don't know I don't
know what I yeah I'm with you I'm with
you a thousand say I think that's part
of the reason why this podcast is really
difficult to talk about because there's
a lot of things that like need to be
said but like II can't fully say sort of
say yeah one thing I will say for sure
though is that I'm I'm I feel like I'm
an air on the side of caution kind of
person when it comes to you know a lot
of the petitions that go around as soon
as someone does something that they
don't like that it's like shut this
person's channel down YouTube if you
don't shut their channel down then
you're you know you're saying that this
is okay and I would always like to err
on the side of caution of like I think
that you know an appropriate thing is to
take the video down strike their channel
just like anybody else do I think that
they need to be banished from the
platform I'm not sure although I know
that they're all
platforms that do do that like Twitter
Twitter blocks people when they think
that there's hate speech going on they
block a lot yeah they do and I think
that there's pros and cons to both ways
but YouTube I think has gone in a
different way because it is a video
sharing platform and a lot of things
fall under the category of video that
are questionable obviously so they try
it seems to err on the side of caution
to where they don't want to just be
deleting people's channels but they do
have to sort of police what is on here
and you know what's good for our
advertisers and what is it but what
borderlines on like freedom of speech
and you know presenting maybe news or
talking about lgbtq+ topics and like you
know I mean like they're they have a lot
of stuff that sort of walks on this
ethical line of like should it be on
YouTube or not yeah you know while still
trying to keep the integrity of we want
people to share in place yeah and they
they do seem to be almost jokingly
[ __ ] haha laissez-faire like they
love to just be this giant corporation
with these elusive [ __ ] rules and
regulations and be like we don't know
that no one to talk to
robotic answers everywhere and there's
there's pros and cons that I feel to
them being so laissez-faire a lot of it
I think is good and powerful because you
know even even just 10 years ago for for
some of the content that's on there
today would it would be an outrage I
can't believe you're letting these
people share this stuff I can't believe
you're doing you know I think it's
important to remain progressive in that
sense and that like what's making people
angry
not that this suicide forest thing is a
good example of that but you know what
I'm saying is that I think that sharing
is important and it might not always be
like the zeitgeist at the time for
someone to share it and I understand
people get outraged and this mob
mentality and they want it to stop and
the answer is to shut that person's
channel down but that's why they have
the strikes and stuff in place and I
feel like my position has almost always
been I agree that YouTube should remain
as hands-off as they can you know
there's there's a lot of great
and be I'm not envious of their job to
try and decide what should and shouldn't
be on YouTube it's a [ __ ] mess like
so you're saying like it's not that
place to be determining contents no I'm
saying that they stay hands-off and my
position has always been a little more
conservative or like err on the side of
caution rather than anybody something
that I don't like delete their channels
back to my job yeah it circles back to
like the sand pepper thing when we're
talking about people like delete is
Challenger like no like you can't just
delete someone's or PewDiePie a lot of
different examples where people are like
you need to delete their channel how
dare you and I've always been the one
that's like or have been in the position
of I think we should err on the side of
caution because then then once you start
getting into that territory then people
are getting you know struck down by the
hand of YouTube and like we don't know
where it's coming from or why like I
feel like some of the videos getting
taken down demonetised like certainly a
lot of people have a lot of questions
and you know nothing is getting
clarified certainly nothing has become
more clear the more they explain things
which right now is nothing but I would
rather have people being like hey
YouTube why is this video demonetised
hey YouTube bye to this video get taken
down hey YouTube license this hitting
some sub boxes rather than I'm not
allowed to have a channel because I'm a
controversial person you don't I mean
yeah and well I mean to argue that point
in so many ways when when when certain
channels are hit with relentless D
monetization they're kind of not able to
have a channel right well that's that's
what I'm saying is they're not envious
of this their responsibility to sort of
try and sort out what we can monetize
what we can't what's what's appropriate
for this platform what's not you know
what's infringing on our Terms of Use
which are vague on purpose so that they
can sort of enforce them whenever they
want to I'm not envious of that job I
want envious of them deciding what this
platform should be because there's a lot
of responsibility like a lot of what
Twitter does when they ban people is
because they're using it for you know
recruiting for terrorism groups and
Twitter's like we can't have that we
have to tell eat this
so YouTube maybe doesn't have that
problem because they've deemed all of
that just inappropriate for this site
but then when we talk about it in the
news that also now is inappropriate and
then
you know it's really gray it's really
bizarre but instead of being like hey
Philip DeFranco you can't talk about the
news we're gonna shut your channel down
because you won't shut up about the news
they just did monetize them so I'm not
it's I'm not sure that anybody
complicated yeah which I think we need
to agree on do we agree that's
incredibly complex greed that I agree
the job of the person at YouTube or the
group of people who have to decide
what's allowed and what's not is the
complicated issue and it's not right or
wrong yeah yeah so but I think it
definitely goes you know deeper but yeah
for sure but so when I saw this whole
thing with people being like you know
YouTube needs to do something I'm
usually the person that's like I think
that when once YouTube does that for one
person then it opens Pandora's box I'm
gonna eat those words right now for in
this situation they need black oh sorry
this was really you know long-winded to
get here but like the lack of response
on this is unacceptable
it's absolutely [ __ ] unacceptable
like I can't even believe it the fact
that a video that defines violating your
Terms of Use is trending on number one
and YouTube year after year after year
refused to describe to us how and why
videos are chosen to be on that place to
be on trending they say it's like oh it
doesn't even really impact your views or
whatever we don't know it's just you
know it's this fun little thing no like
I understand that some of its like they
don't want to perfectly disclose it like
they're cherry-picking it's
cherry-picking terrific it's absolutely
by is cherry-picking some group of
people are youtuber like okay this is
what's great and they don't want to say
that and then a video that will have
30,000 views will be on there and all
the comments are like why the [ __ ] is
this on training I don't get it
I get why you need to pull in new stuff
or smaller stuff you want it to be a
curated little like here's some stuff
you might want to check out today fine
then [ __ ] say that but to have a
video on there that literally defines
violating your Terms of Use
well how we need an explanation for at
least that and I'm not saying I'm still
not in the thought of like YouTube
YouTube needs the delete logan paul's
channel but
should suffer the same consequences as
anyone else in that position there
should be a strike on his channel I
don't know if he's gotten one but the
fact that that was trending so they
never took it down they didn't give his
channel a strike and said they let a
trend they let Logan Paul take it down
they allowed videos to be reuploaded of
it those also transit in other countries
and then anyone discussing the topic
with other videos we're getting flagged
not for like graphic content which you
think maybe they would be but for like
misleading content I forget what the
name of it is for having a misleading
title and thumbnail so not it doesn't
even make any sense and it just it
really irritates me that like yeah even
in the past with the ad pocalypse with
PewDiePie saying the n-word you know the
community gets outraged and YouTube
seemingly at some point if it's going
down they give their stance on it and
it's final you don't mean in the past
that's what's happened so I don't know
how long we need to wait here for them
to [ __ ] say something but it's
unacceptable for them to just not you
know I'm saying 100% agree and I think
it's if there was ever a clear violation
of whatever terms of [ __ ] service
[ __ ] that they've that they have
claimed to have in place this video is
it it is a living breathing proof test
subject literally what you are not
anyone is allowed to do on YouTube and
yet this is gonna trend oh but oh don't
[ __ ] talk about this [ __ ] or you're
gonna be demonetized
this is he's on YouTube Bret okay he can
[ __ ] do it right and I know there's
literally no other conclusion we can
draw here right yeah they didn't say
anything that's that's lit this is this
is us just describing a chain of events
we're not giving our opinions on
anything like this is what [ __ ]
happened here at and I know we're not
comparing apples oranges here but
PewDiePie did say a racist word in a not
cool way and he was stripped of his
YouTube read show and this is not a
one-to-one comparison no it's not but
like there's a lot of stuff going going
on with no response from YouTube and
both Jake and Logan they'll have their
show have YouTube red shows we
any title address from YouTube and this
not even like we're postponing filming
yeah or we're gonna look into nothing
not even we're gonna look into it all
anyways just gonna [ __ ] say it but
like the YouTube part really pisses me
off it means really and it makes it so
smaller creators there's a bigger and
bigger and bigger and gap we've known
this about YouTube Pro a while now then
it truly used to be a democratized
platform with no barrier to entry and
now it is even more difficult for
someone who just wants to get started
and pick up a camera today to get to
where they want to be in place in
YouTube
if that's their goal there's no longer a
zero barrier to entry it is relatively
difficult yeah I get it but like YouTube
by not saying anything and by showing
this that he was able to have this video
number one trending no consequences
YouTube red show and you're crushing the
little guys on YouTube for making lgbtq+
content is like mind-blowing to me
mind-blowing and we're not gonna accept
this like we're looking into it [ __ ]
anymore if you are looking into it Logan
Paul's video would have been uploaded
and then immediately flagged and as if
the moment okay first of all as if the
moment Logan Ball uploads any video a
team of people aren't notified at
YouTube and they may really watch it
he's got a team over there okay number
two that video was up for a way way way
too long time for any excuse YouTube now
gives to be valid there's no oh we
didn't have time to determine or we were
cross-referenced blue there you had a
[ __ ] million hours dude that video is
up for a day almost that video is up for
so [ __ ] long there's no excuse for
the fact that everyone was able to like
literally watch a dead body and be
scarred by it and you guys couldn't do
so much as to maybe maybe just remove
the video not to mention the whole
[ __ ] going on with YouTube kids and
not discussing us of what's going on I
mean this wait like yeah there's been
situations in the past where we need
clarification
we're asking for clarification and
YouTube sort of gives us this robot II
answer that no one wants or it clarifies
nothing fine whatever but at this point
they they basically just got caught in a
flat-out lie I just I honestly can't
believe they didn't release any like any
sort of anything I mean well it's
shocking it's shocking and they're like
I'm literally I'm gonna be a betting man
here and say that this video it's gonna
be titled Logan Paul the podcast I think
it'll get demonetized
but I think it will I think ya know I'll
check I'm gonna check it when it goes up
but I just can't imagine how I would
feel if I was a creator smaller than
Logan Paul which is literally every
creator ever except for like you he's
gonna pass you with this maybe about six
hours but I can't imagine if I did
commentary on my youtube channel it's
just nothing wrong with doing that as
channel there's a lot of great
commentary channels but if you made a
video like reflecting off of something
that really [ __ ] you up and you wanted
to be honest with your audience or even
you're a vlogger whatever you're
dressing the whole logan paul aki go are
forced situation and you got struck or
demonetized right flagged for
inappropriate content when that bit when
you when you upload you're like okay
here's me reacting to the world and
here's me being honest giving my take on
something that really genuinely affected
me which I can communicate about YouTube
oh that's demonetized meanwhile let's
check the training page Logan Paul does
I don't know if there's no other way to
really cut it for me right now because
there's no there's just there's no
argument for them right is there an
argument for them no but that that's
what's so ugly about this situation is
like you know the the argument has
always sort of boiled down to we are a
relatively self policing community we
need to talk about these things and the
best we can do when something happens
and YouTube won't sort of take action
which we've debated a lot in the past
but whether or not it's right for you to
take action whether or not they should
whether or not see responsibility you
know I still think that there's a lot of
gray area there so the most we can do is
sort of talk about it but if there
take away your voice to talk about it
there you're just gonna delete the
videos or like give your channel is
strike but not Logan's now we have a
real problem you're creating a disparity
of wealth a barrier to entry and now
you're making it so people can't have an
opinion about it and I want to say too
about his apology video what when
Twitter has something on Twitter moments
and it's training number one like I get
let's let's give YouTube the benefit of
the doubt for one second
so they put maybe this video number one
on training here's a wild fairy even
though I know it's not true but maybe
they put that video number one on
training because he's sort of an
unsavory character to YouTube even
though we know that's not true he's on a
you to YouTube red shows he's on the
movie the finish this is in a world
where YouTube views Logan Paul as like
we don't like him alright so they put
that the the suicide video number one on
training because they want to sort of
show the world hey guys this kid uploads
every day he could in theory be on the
training page every single day we chose
today because you want we want it we
want to show everybody what a [ __ ]
he is let's imagine that world okay
second world let's let's trend his
apology number one because we want
everyone to know that he's sorry we're
just gonna let him you know show off his
own true colors yes whatever yeah he
monetized that apology but there were no
comments on the video the important
thing to me about Twitter is like when
they when when a number one trending
topic is controversial and it's number
one there are X amount of tweets about
the first thing that you see is the
discussion yeah you know oftentimes even
before you can click on a link to a
story or see what's actually going on
you see people's opinions about it but
if you trend something number one
without any type of conversation going
on in there it's just feeding more into
this machine the fact that something can
trend number one without any comments
wow you know what I mean if if someone's
apology video regardless of what it is
has no type of discussion or
conversation going on
it should not be training number one
people shouldn't be able to click on
that and then silently think their own
thoughts there has to be a discussion in
my opinion or else it's just feeding
into the machine
it's good point you don't I mean the
video is no longer there the video is
deleted so you've deleted everyone's
discussion about it the the apology
video is trending
there's no comments on it the discussion
doesn't exist and then you have people
trying to have a conversation in their
own videos that are getting diluted
there is no conversation when you are
taking away people's voices that is
unacceptable when you don't don't
acknowledge the fact that you allowed
this to happen that violates your Terms
of Use
why does little game Paul get to violate
the Terms of Use but people that want to
have sex on YouTube can't you know what
I'm saying like if they wanted to have a
pornhub YouTube section you know they
can't but if Logan ball wants to do
whatever the [ __ ] he wants to he can not
a good comparison but you know what I'm
saying if if you're gonna make rules I
understand that there's some gray area
there's some link over them the needs to
happen in order for them you can't have
like blanket black and white rules that
would be a mess and we know that there's
human aspects that go into that but you
can't have one of your top creators
blatantly just breaking the rules with
absolutely no comment or consequences
it's ridiculous or conversation I mean
if you're gonna play favoritism at least
hide it a little bit they like made no
effort none none and Jake Paul has a
youtube red show as well and I've always
said this about YouTube is that they
have everything completely [ __ ]
backwards and we talked about this when
we talk about our YouTube
representatives people that we've heard
from a YouTube and everyone has the same
thing to say they are number crunching
robots that give you number crunching
robot answers when you have questions or
concerns they it's like they have
pre-programmed things to say to you that
are all incredibly vague and answer
absolutely none of your questions
because all that matters to them is
numbers which is the worst possible way
to go about becoming a you know a
competition to traditional television or
film if you want people to take you
seriously you can't just like ride the
wave of what everyone's paying attention
to at the current moment you have to
remember why YouTube is even cool in the
first place exactly
which they've completely forgotten this
but you see people come and go and you
know it's it's naive of a 22 year old to
think like I'm on an unstoppable
rocketship and growth is forever is
someday I'm just gonna have like you
know 7 billion subs we
that's how many [ __ ] people there are
in the world like it's not gonna happen
you know and YouTube is so quick to
hitch their ladder to whatever is
blowing up this year which I just think
is irresponsible there's so many people
like when the first round of YouTube red
shows came around and they offered it to
like good mythical morning and and Smosh
you know people have proven themselves
like here I have a decade of work that
shows you I'm a professional and I take
my job seriously and I'm not here to
[ __ ] around and be a douchebag and then
you see YouTube hitch their ladders so
people like [ __ ] Logan and Jake Paul
who I like what [ __ ] what didn't you
guys start like a year ago yeah this is
what happens though when you guys crunch
numbers for a living and only play by
numbers this is what happens a YouTube
has lost a lot of our respect and the
the Paul Brothers have lost the respect
of the community so you all want to get
[ __ ] buried together Oh like what you
want to do I don't know I mean I don't
know and the reason that everyone I see
calling all the time that's like if
youtubers are so upset with YouTube why
don't you just make your own platform a
ridiculous and practice what would be
ridiculous actually do but be we've we
love YouTube we want YouTube to be
better but part of doing that is that
they have no accountability above their
head YouTube is sort of the end-all
be-all Google is sort of you know BL for
them like they don't have to answer to
anyone above that which sucks because
that level of arrogance e arrogance
rather is like is no it's not productive
to them nor the creators it's like a
good example of of this is like you
looked at the patreon situation where a
couple weeks ago patreon rolled out a
whole new system of how they were going
to take payments on how they were taking
a percentage and they didn't tell anyone
they just rolled it out and there was a
huge outrage all the patreon users
supporters were like whoa whoa whoa what
the [ __ ] is this I did not agree to this
my career is based off patreon which is
a lot of people this is not cool you
know mass outrage and they were like
where's all right I'm sorry guys we're
gonna not do that thank you for telling
us like has YouTube literally ever done
anything even remotely like that no no
and that's how much could they been
affirmed it benefit from it oh so much
heaps even just to show the people that
their voices are not nothing right and
it would benefit the platform like crazy
I know they're ginormous player and
they're in the internet space obviously
the number one whatever but oh my god
how how far would that go if they just
proved once I'm sorry
even on a [ __ ] ecology dude even
tweeted hey where we're looking in you
know just one [ __ ] moment of being a
human that you're not this giant machine
robot that's here to crush everyone but
Logan Paul like just one second of like
humility where we can just kind of feel
a little bit safe here yeah it goes so
long it goes such a long way and it's it
hasn't been done in and as long as I can
remember about YouTube and I uh and in
the time that they've spent policing and
making rules and being a robot and
shutting people down and not giving a
single moment of like actual clarity or
or real emotion or or communication it's
just grown the distance between the
creators and the platform by by tenfold
and now we feel we're stranded on this
island submitting our videos out to
outer space and whatever happens to them
they're out in outer space now we don't
have communication with outer space
there YouTube if we want a communication
they'll drop a tweet down earth saying
hey at this person will look into this
and you're like okay great I still don't
believe you exist but that's like this
this is one of the most difficult things
though is that all of the people that
you see speaking out about YouTube and
speaking out about Logan and Jake call
you know aside from the celebrities
they're allowed to have their opinions
or anyone that doesn't work in the
YouTube space everyone's allowed to have
their opinions and think and feel how
they feel about what happened it's
difficult for us to talk about this
stuff with YouTube because it's like
biting the hand that feeds you it's
scary sometimes like yeah I don't think
I've had any like weird conspiracies
like someone's coming and trying to burn
out my house or like silence me or like
it deliberately
monetizing my videos but it doesn't make
it any less scary to speak out against
your employer and I want to add
something that I don't I don't think I'm
breaching any sort of contract by saying
but one of the people that I've seen
being incredibly vocal about this Logan
Paul situation is Rosanna pansino who's
like one of the most advertiser friendly
people you could ever possibly imagine
but she I and Logan Paul all have one of
the same representatives over at CAA and
even she is like get [ __ ] this is like
YouTube saying we want YouTube to be a
safe space for creators also YouTube
with shows like their YouTube read show
and like the Logan Paul to come out and
say what she said that was very sermon
this is someone who has a past with
being you know promoted by YouTube she
has the same representative as Logan
Paul as do I over at CAA it's so
difficult it's scary on a lot of levels
like if I criticize Logan Paul at CAA
gonna get mad at me or are they gonna
get mad at Rosanna pansino you see a lot
of people like that aren't only scared
to talk about about YouTube but about
other things for other reasons with
friendships professional relationships
so I mean this is not an easy podcast to
record it's also not a discussion that's
easy for us to have while being honest
but it also it just like it makes me
appreciate on people who use their
voices when they're when they want to
talk about this stuff in a constructive
way and not just uh I'm looking for
retweet so I'd love Justine is another
one I just as a friend I just see ya man
yeah you did something [ __ ] wrong she
passed I've seen if I just seen is
criticizing YouTube openly like come on
yeah come on
I just seems the only reason I ever
started a YouTube channel like good god
dude I don't know I just I feel like
it's it doesn't get any less difficult
to talk about it and the just the topic
in the nature of this was difficult to
talk about but also every time you know
we sit here and openly criticize YouTube
it just gets a little scarier it does
because it's like we won I mean it's
it's hard to think of
it being well-received at YouTube that
were that we are critical of what
they're doing in whatever situation we
might be talking about well yeah it's a
small position because at this way when
they've done something and given no
response they got caught red-handed
letting you know doing blatant
favoritism and not striking someone's
channel or deleting the video and it
blatantly violates the Terms of Use and
not saying anything about it like in the
past when we've done these podcasts it
feels like maybe someone might listen to
us we speak loudly enough as a community
someone might listen to us and at this
point it feels like no one's listening
to us know which is not a good feeling
it's a scary feeling it's scary because
you don't know you don't know what the
[ __ ] gonna happen you don't know
what's going on dude it's wrong it's
[ __ ] wrong and you guys you know if I
were a dink film looking from the
outside and I'd be disappointed if we
sat here every week that had something
controversial and you-tube happen and
just played a game and be like sorry
guys we can't talk about it because
they're paying our bills or like you
know and [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
dude that's and that's not why you guys
are here that's not why you tuned in to
listen to us talk like I know that you
can find that vanilla nonsense
everywhere else but yeah it's not an
easy thing for us to sit down and
comfortably talk about and go to sleep
and wake up and be like okay well you
know everything's fine cuz we don't we
literally have no idea but with all of
that said we hope you guys got something
out of this discussion as always we
encourage you to participate in the
comments section we're gonna go through
and read what you guys have to say we
keep it civil I know you guys always do
but just a friendly reminder that you
know talking down to people or you know
anything is not productive good comment
yeah and don't feel like what we said is
the right answer we want to hear your
your comments on what we have to say but
yes in a very civil way would be nice
because we're human beings and we're not
here to [ __ ] be dicks so thank you
guys for tuning in I'm sweating
hopefully next week we can do something
a lot lighter and more fun and exciting
to talk about but like you said we felt
like it was our kind of
to touch on this yeah
quick now we stream on Twitch if you're
new around here twitch.tv slash
annejulien
we stream games all the time like more
like and it's more like a lot more
custom games in pub G and [ __ ] thank
you guys so much we'll see you next week
for another podcast
[Music]
[Music]